good day everyone and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i'm proud
to welcome you to this edition of our 2021 2022
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series the lecture series is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme for the but for our biomedical
data science seminar series is ethical challenges
of artificial intelligence biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on friday afternoons from
leading thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai applications
in the biomedical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these presentations as
a vital material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be held here
in historic charlottesville virginia next june
applications for the biomedical data science
innovation lab program are being accepted
until january 31st 2022 so please if you
are interested consider applying and or
encourage your junior colleagues to do so we look
forward to reviewing these application materials
for your participation today it is my honor and
privilege to welcome our speaker ms johanna loomba
who's the director of the ithriv informatics corps
here at the university of virginia johanna loomba
has a degree in symbolic systems uh neural systems
from stanford university and a master's degree in
systems engineer from engineering excuse me from
the university of virginia she has extensive
clinical research experience and previously served
as the director of neurosurgery and neuro-oncology
clinical research for the university of virginia
in her role with ithriv johanna is the director
of ithriv the ithriv informatics corps which
is a cross state team working to accelerate
health research by facilitating data transfer and
linking and analyzing data in a secure environment
in addition to designing systems that support
all the ithriv service lines johanna provides
personal consultation to health researchers on
project design implementation and including plans
for data collection for project management and
for data analytics in continuing our 2021-2022
biomedical data science seminar series theme
johanna's lecture today is entitled introduction
to the use of structured medical records
data electronic medical records data emr data
is encoded in patient charts through the course
of clinical care and subsequent patient billing
excuse me coded data in electronic records such
as information stored against standardized codes
provides a vast amount of valuable patient data
yet the effective applying of data science tools
to emr data requires an understanding of the
limitations of those data sets and avoiding
common and false assumptions johanna's going to
address those for us today as she introduces some
common data models cohort exploration tools and
ctsa related resources she's going to specifically
feature examples from the national covid cohort
collaborative to demonstrate approaches to
structured health data access analysis as always
if you are streaming this lecture live and
uh we are streaming this lecture live and for
recording by youtube and if you're watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2021-2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are encouraged
to submit any questions for johanna via the chat
feature in their zoom sessions i will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf during
last 10 minutes or so of johanna's lecture and
with that thank you so much johanna we've been
looking forward to this talk for a year and we're
really glad to have it today thank you so much
thank you jack thank you for having me here so yes
as jack mentioned i'm a clinical researcher and
a systems engineer and i currently serve as the
director of informatics for the nih-funded ithriv
ctsa so we are across virginia collaboration
we work with a lot of public private academic
and community partners and the primary
partners are shown here on the screen
we provide clinical care to about 60 percent
of virginians and one reason we built this
collaboration was to develop systems and
processes that would support efficient cross-state
observational health research that can accelerate
innovation and support evidence-based practice
we also work to support team science by
building bridges between data scientists
and clinical researchers and for much of my
career i managed neurosurgery neuro-oncology
trials and we focused on prospective data
collection but i found that understanding the
challenges of quality prospective data collection
really does inform the observational research
biomedical data science research should
always include team members who understand
that clinical science and the practical
clinical workflows that generate the data
and as you'll hear today the development of the
most powerful coding vocabularies that we have
has really been driven by clinicians and
for those of you here who are clinicians
understanding these topics coverage should help
you better engage with the analysts who you work
with and my aim is to really just flesh out
some foundational concepts so we can establish
a strong foundation for your biomedical team
science and so what are we talking about today
and why this medical record harmonization
is very relevant to both patient care
and research the patients benefit from continuity
of care across sites and the government has also
recognized that in the last decade or so in 2009
the high tech act motivated implementation of
electronic medical records for sites
that didn't already have those in place
and in 2016 the 21st century cares
cures act established plans for tefka
which will support greater interoperability
between those different emrs so that's still in
the works and the first versions expected out
in 2022 which is really exciting so you know
patients also as we know should benefit from
translational research and once harmonized our
vast stores of this clinical record data
can be tapped to solve medical problems
but you know through the covid pandemic this
whole country has come to understand that
research and clinical care are really intertwined
and also understand that the ability to pool our
data is critical if we want to quickly identify
patterns and evaluate interventions and outcomes
we really needed tefka two years ago but
luckily researchers have been working for
decades to harmonize health record data
and thanks to all the prior groundwork
laid academic institutions were able to
work with the nih to quickly spin up the
first massive central repository of row level
health data from patients around this country
and although kovit was the catalyst for this
unprecedent level of of cooperation we've
established tools now that are extensible to
all kinds of research questions and any and all
health domains so this is really a very exciting
time for biomedical research in this country
so this is a summary of what i hope you're
going to gain i'd like you to be able to
name commonly used data models understand
some of the challenges and considerations
around using the coded data know about tools
and resources to help you and and be aware
of some of this work being done by the ctsa
community and the nih to harmonize medical data
coded medical data i think jack provided that
summary in the intro it's really any any of
these facts that we have represented at codes
in the in the chart but it's only the first
step towards harmonization is having those codes
available um our emr data is incredibly complex
and iran counts on the number of emr codes
currently used in the national coveted cohort
collaborative database that we're talking about
today at the time when i i took this snapshot
there were 65 us sites with data on the enclave
there's 67 as of today it's growing all the time
but of those 65 sites there's over
75 vocabularies in use and i've shown
them from the most frequently uh or the highest
counts rather the highest counts of codes in use
and you know going down the list here and i
couldn't fit them all on the screen but there's
over 6.5 million unique codes that are represented
in the patient charts that are in the enclave
right now so really really complex encoding of all
this kind of information that we all want to use
to answer our questions so you can note that the
highest number of codes up in the top most of the
categories for the top represent drugs because we
need a lot of different codes to to identify those
and then that's followed by diagnosis codes
and then you see things for procedures
measurements and observations
labs locations etc you'll notice that snowmen
appears in multiple categories so that can be
used kind of across these different domains and
even within a single vocabulary there can be
a lot of variation in usage between clinical
sites so if you want to explore an example of this
link is is a particularly good example i
provided three articles in the references
that describe complexities around the use and
evolution of light codes how do we analyze data
that's expressed in so many different vocabularies
each with its own hierarchical structure
um i think you all have heard about the fair
principles and we're going to explore approaches
to these principles and we're going to find out
that the first two are easier to achieve than the
last two making your data findable and accessible
dumping billions of rows of data out somewhere
is one thing but really doing that in a meaningful
way where it's interoperable across sites or even
across clinics at your own institution and then
being able to ask questions and come up with
answers using code that's reusable
is a much bigger challenge
what we need is a common data model and that is
a shared language consisting of both the data
elements in one or more vocabularies living inside
of a structure that describes the relationship
between those data elements so the data model is
both of those two things put together you could
say that each emr is in its own way a complex
data model so for example the 20 000 plus
clarity databases that store epic emr data plus
the epic software that defines the relationships
between the database elements together that's
a data model but we have to remember that each
site that implements epic does some amount of
customization so no two epic sites have the same
real emr data model so typically the more
specialized the data the more it varies
between the sites and we have to restructure
our data to really approach harmonization
this typically involves mapping the data
that's stored in your thousands and thousands
of tables to a small set of about 20 or
40 tables while still trying to retain
its meaning and keep in mind that once you
harmonize data there are still inherent in
that patterns local patterns reflective of local
data management practices heterogeneous genius
patient populations and clinical practices once
the data is harmonized it does become possible
to observe these site level variations in a way
that can't be achieved just using a single site
most academic health centers in the us
have mapped their data to one of these
common data models and the map data is used
to support any number of analytic tools
so you may not recognize the terms here you may
or may not but you would definitely recognize the
tools that you use that sit on top of those so
note that the counts here are a little outdated
as i pulled this from a 2019 publication
pertaining to all of us research program
and the count for sites using omop is definitely
higher now that is the fastest growing data model
and is used for most of the national international
harmonized research so i just a couple things
to point out here because people will make
statements about one of these being better
than the other and just kind of understanding
what makes them different fundamentally
pcornet has a traditional relational database
that it uses and the tables represent familiar
clinical domains pretty intuitive with diagnoses
and labs and mets each living in their own table
where i2b2 uses a star schema model and so
it has one large fact table that has all of
those individual observations stacked together
regardless of domain and then it has different
ontology tables that describe the hierarchical
relationships between the rows and the fact table
and then omop is a hybrid of those two so it
kind of takes the best of both and we have the
domain tables like we do in pcornet and then an
individual concept table that becomes kind of
like a data dictionary containing all of the terms
and then other concept relationship tables as well
so here are some of the tools that make use
of this data well epic is actually just taking
the raw underlying data out of your your epic
slicer dice or rather taking your local emr data
and displaying that through through a query
mechanism not all epic data is provided in epic
slicer dicer it has to be implemented at the site
level and it is pretty limited in its interface
um and then we have you know beef and trinet x
as other examples of tools and these are running
off of uh structured data itude b2 data or itv2
oromop in the case of trinetics or pcornet so
does this make your data more findable and
accessible at least an aggregate yes does
um but do the queries really expose the
full complexity of the underlying data
i would say no we've already talked about how
the emrs are different across sites and so slicer
dicer is really not interoperable and then you
know leaf and trinidex require that mapping so we
have some harmonization to a cdm but they're not
implemented in the same way by all sites so for
example trinetx does not dictate whether ordered
inpatient meds that are not actually administered
to the patient appear in the data set and it
doesn't provide a flag so you might have some
sites where a whole bunch of things that were
ordered and not given are exposed as patient
meds and you might have another site where
only the given inpatient meds are exposed
and at uva we have a data dictionary available
to our users that explains that we are
selecting just the given inpatient meds and then
any ordered outpatient meds but you know that's
that kind of dictionary distinction is not
available across sites who are using trinetx
so we really need to define the structure of our
underlying data and harmonize our data to make our
queries more interoperable across sites there's
a lot of ways that large medical data sets are
shared and i'm just giving you a few examples
here to illustrate a range of approaches with
regards to interoperability and and reuse and on
the high entropy end of the scale we have those
globally scoped data repositories they accept a
wide range of data types in a variety of formats
and they don't really impose a coherent model
and then the federated model which is used
in act as an example you can query across
sites but really there's no sharing of the
underlying row level data and so we can't under
we can't really understand the differences of how
that result came about we just get the aggregate
answer coming back from the site and then we have
centralized data where all the row level data is
combined prior to cleaning and analysis and so n3c
is the example today and i will spend some more
time talking about that project and the omop data
that it uses i've also included in the reference
slides a reference to paper i worked on with emily
faff and a bunch of others who are working
in n3c and illustrates how centralizing our
data in one place has really helped us
better understand our differences and
bridge those gaps and even enhance our local
data mappings and increasing operability and
even increasing the quality of the federated
queries that we're doing outside of n3c
so now i'll go a little deeper into the omoph
common data model as i had said before it does
build off of the strengths of the previously
developed data models and it's a partnership
between the fda nih pharma and academia at this
point and it's a mechanism and a nice quote
here a mechanism to standardize the structure
content and semantics of observational data
and to make it possible to write statistical
code once that can be reused at every data
site so that's the vision and worldwide we got
lots of volunteers working on on this data model
the community that's gathered around it is odyssey
and it's an open science community that builds and
also validates tools that that sit on top of this
data model a really rich set of open source tools
um so i've given you a link here to
this online book about about odyssey
and omop and it's really really helpful
and you might be particularly interested in
chapters four and five for your work so take
a look at that it's really well organized
and then if you want to learn more about the stuff
we've talked about so far there's a good tutorial
from the 2019 odyssey symposium
that i would recommend
so this is an illustration of the omop
clinical data model domains and again
you can see that we have these kind of domain
based tables intuitive types of facts in them
each representing person level data and the person
table itself contains some basic demographics
about those people we have location data we have
derived elements where we look across time at
things and see the start and stop of conditions or
drugs and if we of course have some standardized
metadata about the source facts and here's
all these relational tables the concept table
which is like a data dictionary and then a lot of
things describing the relationships between them
so here's a little peek into one entry in the
concept table all of the source concepts are
indexed in the concept table along with a mapping
to a hierarchical omop code so odyssey maintains
the standard set of codes typically snomed
lincoln rx norm so three or just a few
vocabularies are used rather than 75 plus
and they also maintain the hierarchical
relationships between those codes and so we have
complete mappings from all non-standard codes
to a set of standard codes with a much more
discrete set of hierarchies that define them
so this is really um wonderful work that's
being done you know across across the world that
makes this uh makes this clinical
data model so so powerful
so omap relies heavily on snowmed ct whenever it's
possible it uses it for the standard vocabulary
and this slide is an excerpt from the national
library of medicine websites you can go there that
kind of abbreviated their history here to just
pull out a few of the facts but it does show how
snomed efforts really originated from work being
done by pathologists to standardize the anatomical
descriptions and then the development continued
to be driven by clinicians not like billing
practices like some of our other coding systems
so i will note that icd-11 which is coming out
is much more tightly aligned to snomed so it's
starting to converge towards the standard itself
at the 2020 symposium odyssey symposium benjamin
b ernest and his team presented the poster that
shows the power of using the snomed ct hierarchy
compared to the icd hierarchy in terms of the
completeness and the richness of data captured
and he was looking particularly at computation
of the charleston comorbidity index using the
two systems and snomed was the clear winner
based on their work they used some veteran
affairs data and they saw higher average cmi
scores when they applied snowmen so i
kind of replicated this exercise in n3c
and found that their fightings hold through
in this much much larger data set as well
on this slide i show counts for total concept
sets in just a congestive heart failure concept
set created with the two methods so if you use
snomed you can identify one parent code and
use all of its descendants and map codes you
get 428 source codes included compared to
using icd codes where you have the 24 icd codes
that were originally uh recognized as part of
the this comorbidity and the charleston
comorbidity index and if you take all of its
descendants and all of its map codes you get 231
and you know a review of those concepts shows that
relevance holds up in these and there are maybe
a couple in here that that might not um apply
so i provided a few links for you all
here so you can explore these hierarchies
there's these are publicly available tools that
sit on top of the omop data model and give you
kind of a way to look into the guts of it so
athena is a great one to look at for exploring the
vocabs and the hierarchies and then atlas is one
of those tools another tool that's created by
the odyssey community it's open source you might
have an atlas instance stood up at your particular
institution that's sitting on top of your omop
data but there are a few public instances also for
that anyone can log on and use and this is one
where they they use some large international data
sets as the underlying data so you can get a sense
of kind of the frequency of use of different codes
because it's actually tied to real data and
then also be looking at those hierarchical
relationships that we saw in athena so here's an
example you can go on you can even search this
example if you go in here you can you can mess
with it too you can mess with my example because
everyone can can change each other's things
in this system but so this is a ischemic code
ischemic stroke code set and i've selected
just eight standard codes and their descendants
and then any non-standard codes that are mapped
to them and that results in a total of 835
included source concepts so by grabbing just
a few and trusting the work of the community
you can grab all of them very quickly or you
can go and review all of the included concepts
one by one and ensure they really do you know
fit your purposes and exclude any that do not
so let's talk a little more about n3c as an
example of centralized omap data this partnership
was facilitated by ncats and also cd2h which is
a kind of cross ctsa group working on informatics
they provide centralized secure portal for storage
and analysis of patient-level clinical data
to answer questions related to covid19 there's
two websites provided here and i encourage you
to go and take a look and get involved if you
are not already it's a great learning environment
and a lot of open meetings and domain teams that
you can join and a really easy place to plug in to
trying to learn to work with this complex data
whose data is in n3c so the intention of this
again is to answer questions about covid so all of
the participating local sites run a query to find
patients who've had a positive cova test
this actually includes uh pcr ag or even
antibody so at this point that's that could just
indicate vaccine as well or a cova diagnosis
and it includes some suspected cases from january
to may of 2020 when we didn't have the testing and
the and the diagnosis codes available to us
so there's a you have to have more than one
number of diagnoses to be included in this
group so it selects all those patients and
some of their records that will show
and then it also selects two control
patients for every every included patients and
these may or may not have had covid but they at
least had um some code at least one cova test
present with a negative result to be included
and then which data is transmitted
it's all of the major medical facts
from from the participating sites as long as it's
from been recorded since the beginning of 2018 to
now so we don't have their whole lifetime of chart
data and of course emrs kind of vary in in their
length of time that they represent but
everyone has data from 2018 forward and
all of those facts are sent and all of the data
from those main all mop tables comes through
and you don't have to have omap to
participate and you actually can
have i2b2 or rpcornet if you participate
in any of trinidx or pcornet you can have
your data transferred in from your site or
omop you can send directly your omop data in
the data transfer agreements executed
there's a central irb from hopkins that we
rely on and um the etl is is performed
periodically typically once a week for us
it's once a week at our institution um to send
this data and that's ingested harmonized so if
you didn't come from an omap data model they take
your model and map it onto omop and then you have
it available based on the approval you get you
have to request use under a data use request
which may or may not require an irb depending on
the level of data you're trying to access in your
own local practices but the platform helps you
manage all that in addition to the limited data
set there's actually de-identify data which is not
shown here with date shifted that's date shifted
data and then also synthetic data which is derived
um and you know synthetically recreated from the
from the existing data and provides an
even higher level of de-identification
so here's a snapshot from november 11th and at
that time we had 67 sites 9.2 million patients
over 3 million copied positive
patients over 10 billion rows of data
so really a lot of information it's a little
overwhelming the first time you face it
and ithriv in n3c we've had a really good time
working with with this community um it's been such
an honor and a great thing for our institution to
be involved and it continues to be that um so we
are involved in the neurodomain team myself and um
the the pis from ithriv and a number of clinicians
from uva then also from other sites like emory and
um university of miami we all lead a neuro domain
team and if you look on the main website there's
this is our domain team but there's all kinds of
domain teams you can join it's it's a really great
thing and then we also lead the logic liaison team
and that's just a group of people who we found
all of the coders working for the different
domain teams and come together kind of formed
a work group where we can focus our efforts
and create some generic tools for the community
at large within a domain team a logic liaison
will help you know go from those those billions
of rows of data to some discrete variables that
can be used in a project so for example we saw
the ischemic stroke concept set so we went from
hundreds of codes to eight codes to to one you
can name it put it together into one concept set
and then out of that you can use that in a complex
variable like uh you know if you wanted to do a
covet and stroke variable where you're looking
for the first instance of one of those codes
and it has to be admitted with an admission and
it has to have had a coveted positive test in a
specific time period leading up to the stroke
all of that logic can can produce a single
derived variable that can be used to define
a cohort or to be used as an independent or
dependent variable in an analysis and when we
do that kind of work we actually have ways that
we can share it back with the community as well
so that people are not all recreating the wheel
so in working in n3c we run into the same
kinds of challenges and limitations that we see
with with all coded health data um you know you
really can't lose sight of those nuances when
you're creating those kind of derived variables
or using them if somebody has produced it for you
for using a statistical or machine learning model
we have to think about how did the code appear in
the chart again what was that underlying clinical
workflow and when might something be captured or
not captured is this patient report is this an
official diagnosis was it an ordered medication
or given medication do we know do we have to know
for the particular question that we're asking is
it really important to know the distinction there
um you know the start date the first time that you
see a code might not be the time it actually
started someone could have experienced the
condition previously in their medical history but
walked in the door for the first time at your site
and had it recorded for the first time there
so you might need to look again at coinciding
with a number of other codes that it would
indicate a real event for the first time
like an admission with a stroker certain kinds
of imaging happening at the same time are drugs
also remember that medical record data is always
inherently incomplete so you think about all the
people flowing through to n3c where they were just
seen for a cova test and they never went back to
that medical center so just because they don't
have a complete medical history doesn't mean that
they have no comorbidities so if you just look you
know for the presence of comorbidities and assume
everybody else was a negative for that you're
misinterpreting the data but you can look for some
you know richness in the data and only include
patients who have a certain number of say visits
or facts before an event happened or after
event happened and limit your analysis to those
working with inpatients is a good way to make sure
you're focused on patients who did have some more
comprehensive data collected at the medical center
but it really depends on your research question
what's appropriate for you with all medical record
data we have racial biases and data collection
practices even before it ever comes to us there
could be differences in care provided to patients
or access to care and there could be issues with
the collection of the race and ethnicity data
we know that it's not always self-reported
information unfortunately sometimes it's assumed
and recorded by a registrationist and their
systems might not always allow for things like
multiple race values so you know just because
something looks simple you know we have to still
remember that that it underneath
that there's a lot of complexity
and then of course medical records
from a specific institution
never represent a true random sample of the
population at that locality so you know we can't
look at say the rates of of uh comorbidities and
encoded patients in n3c and say that's a rate
for the entire country it's just for those
patients and the people who seek care at a
medical center of course are going to tend
to be sicker than the population at large
you're not getting as many of the the healthy
patients are people with fewer issues going on
and then also like we've talked about before
there's variation in clinical practice across
sites and even departments and clinicians and
it also changes over time all of our all of our
practices change over time the coding practices
as well as the things that surround it and
covet is a great example where we know that
you know vaccines change things a great deal
so i think we're all becoming familiar with these
concepts and then some diagnosis information might
live only in notes and text mining is complex
it's not always an option we're working to
incorporate more of that into n3c with some text
mining done externally in your notes data with
some kind of aggregated information or derived
information flowing through that's in process
so be intentional with how you handle your
data heterogeneity including over time
right and a lot of observational health data
has those different kinds of missingness
i talked about a little bit already so
if you create a flag for bmi over 30
a patient might have a zero flag for this feature
because all of their reported bmis were under 30.
but they also might get a zero value for this
feature if there are no bmi measurements flowing
over from their site at all and ideally these zero
values are handled you know differently during
data cleaning or filtering our imputation so look
for those patterns of of missingness in your data
in general you're going to have a bigger data
set it's it's messier and it might become more
opaque to you what are those underlying practices
because you're not directly connected with all of
the clinical teams producing that data so be
explicit about your assumptions and and test
them when you're working with this kind of data
and for the analysts we have to think about which
type of model should be used there's definitely a
place for both explanatory and predictive modeling
we do usually see more of the explanatory
models with clinical data because they're
easier to interpret and apply
and then the predictive modeling
is really less about the why and more about
accurate forecasting of what's going to happen
but i liked this quote from schmule here that the
consequence of neglecting to include predictive
modeling and testing alongside explanatory
modeling is losing the ability to test the
relevance of ex of existing theories and
discover new causal mechanisms so you know
it's really the one informs the other and you
may need to kind of use the two side by side
so just a few summary data science considerations
apply to most work that you're ever going to do
even outside of this domain but make sure the
problems represented in the available data
that you're actually getting all the facts
you need if you're doing something about
ventilation of these patients do you
really do you really have all the
ventilator settings and things that might be
pertinent to your question that type of thing
um after harmonizing the data you do have to
think about that that aggregation and make
sure you record all your decisions you're
making as you aggregate that data so that
it's reproducible by other people including like
the concept set creation and the logic around it
with training and testing you might consider
with medical record data doing the split
using time intervals so you can look for test
your models to see how well do they handle data
as it changes over time at a clinical site and
then external validation is always important
with the this centralized data in n3c we have an
opportunity to do external validation by first
training on a number of sites data training
and testing there and then kind of deploying
it out to data from other partners who are
contributing data and seeing how it performs there
and of course there's no free lunch
and you know at some point maybe
the problem that you're looking at at one
institution or one set of institutions
is essentially really not the same
problem at another institution so
even giving them the same model to train on their
own data might not be appropriate in every case
i wanted to point out these um nice odyssey r
libraries that are available for your use there's
again so much material out there from odyssey but
it's good to highlight some some of the really
useful stuff so the feature extraction library
pro lets you leverage those snomed codes to create
those commonly used clinical variables take a
look at that it's got good documentation around it
and then there's a whole set of
packages for patient level prediction
and uh that helps you again extract your
data to create variables from a mop and then
develop and validate models for all target and
outcome cohort validation or combinations and
it makes use of all kinds of different models
and regression and machine learning models and
it also supports custom models that you create
and there are packages included for plotting and
model performance and things like that on a
shiny app so you can visualize your results
so i i wanted to talk a little bit share a little
bit of the vision from the ncats and nih about use
of this data you know n3c has provided nih and the
federal government with a successful example of
what it's like to centralize data in a secure
enclave and they're now making plans to enhance
and generalize this model for use beyond
cobin 19. all of this federated work and
kind of project by project trying to find
the data and transfer between institutions
and store it has constituted so much work for
people doing research around the country and
they're really realizing that the value add
and cost savings by centralizing our data
so for when they they plan to provide translation
software the bulk emr extract the bulk fire
extract from our emr aligns with the tefka
requirements that are coming out the previously
mentioned 21st century cures act that supports
that exchange of data between emrs bulk fire is
really like a language i can speak to your emr and
pull those facts out and uh nih will provide all
of us participants with those tools you know to to
actually go both ways from fire to one of the data
models or use data that you have in one of the
data models to communicate with other entities
that need to use that data like the cdc or the
fda or you know any of your nih research teams
and i also want to enhance the secure enclave by
supporting project-based spin-off environments
they call it the tenant model and these would
support two or more institutions that are
trying to do networked uh medical record
research and the appropriate data you know
it would already all be housed since they would
have all the underlying data but they can make a
subset of that available um projects per
specific partition in the enclave along with
all of those rich analytic tools that are being
developed by the research community at large
this is really exciting and and will help
us all not have to recreate the wheel so
many times and build you know a whole set
of tools that we can share and use together
so i have some key takeaways for you
most of all we'd like that i like to
know your medical coding vocabularies
understand which one you're using or
or several that you're using and then leverage
those community tools like the odyssey resources
that i described to create groups of codes
for your derived variables in your data set
and use data that is mapped to
common data models whenever possible
apply standard data science good practices
test your assumptions strive for completeness
consistency and uniformity and work with your
domain experts to understand data collection
and work on variable definition and
problem design it's really a team
science problem don't recreate the wheel
and use those community developed libraries
so in conclusion i just want to say it's not
our software systems alone that require common
language it's our research teams also we have
to become fluent in a common language so that
our clinicians our informations and
analysts can effectively partner together
and do rigorous and reproducible science using
this real world data and i believe that the future
of clinical translational research really revolves
around bioinformatics and by work by working to
use and improve the evolving systems around us we
can all help move this field forward and i think
that's all i have i have some references
at the end for you all to take a look at
johanna thank you so much that was a wonderful
overview of the various sources of uh structural
medical records data um thank you so much for
sharing that with us um i was impressed where
you on one of your slides you mentioned 6.5
million unique codes uh that is a staggering
number of codes i'm kind of curious they how that
gets to be 6.5 million unique codes i presume that
you know somebody makes these up what happens to
the to codes that exist and like when can they be
revised or remapped do they get retired or does
the list just grow right it never gets smaller
it only grows longer as people just add more and
more codes but what happens in those instances
yeah they they do get retired and remapped so you
know there are different groups that manage the
different vocabularies but you're familiar with
icd codes coming out with different versions and
so you know the entire version changes and even
the hierarchies they use and the codes they use
can change entirely and in a way the old one is
sunset at sunsetted but you can't forget about
it because all this previous that's right was used
with those codes right and so you have to maintain
those mappings from the old ones right to the
new and or from all of them to standard codes
the omop data model is being updated all the
time and then you know we get we get the kind of
updates ingested into n3c on a regular basis so
it's a big community effort and there are formats
where you can give feedback to um to have that
to have the revised if you you know recognize
that there are problems with it but yeah it is it
is an issue it's there's always version control
with everything that you do in informatics so
you have to be mindful of that yeah i'm working
with some students now who are working with the
unos um organ transplant database and it's a huge
database it covers every medical center in
the country and it's been around long enough
that it's gone through several revisions and
there's a whole several places where there
in our discussions with them say oh yeah we don't
really use that term anymore it's really we use
this term or rather they do a number of other
things so you're really overriding all of this
is dealing with the evolution of the particular
database in question would you agree with that
yeah i agree and i i think that yeah you you
have to do two things you kind of start with
relying on work done by the community especially
if you're using able to use omop um but then you
can backtrack from there and and say do i really
trust this and like i was saying kind of dive into
a particular list of codes to see or work with the
teams that generated the data for any particular
database to find out the true provenance of
that i i try to go you know through each each
type of code we're using and say how is this
code generated what are all the circumstances
where this code would be generated and you know
often what you see is that the clinicians who are
you know conceptualizing the problem think of
a code as used by them and don't necessarily
think of all the broad range of cases where it
can be used so if you have tools like trinetics
at your disposal or leaf you know you can take
a look at those codes and see other plate other
instances where it's used in other um you kind
of surface these cohorts that maybe a clinician
would not have thought about these patient
cohorts where where that kind of code is
is used so do some exploring you know we every
single project we work on it seems easy at first
pass every pass right now it
surfaces more questions and
of course you have to pick and choose at some
point and decide where are we really adding value
so it's also important you know you might have the
6.5 billion um codes used but if one only appears
three times or something and you don't want to
spend too much time worrying about that particular
code right so um yeah you it's important to look
at use you know the rate of use for the underlying
facts as well yeah so with 6.5 million unique
codes there's probably a frequency at which some
of them get used more than others it is probably
helpful to know about that uh as you're as you're
looking through i i completely agree with your
statement that bioinformatics and being able to
process these uh being experienced with this
is really helpful um and it one should take the
time to be able to um you know educate oneself
about which resource they happen to be using
i'm curious though if you know
where you have these codes which
usually they've been standardized or certainly
they've been decided upon by either the developers
or the community around them i'm curious
though are there also um blocks of free text
that are associated with any of these that say
maybe suitable for natural language processing or
trying to use information in clinical notes for
example to then inform which codes one might want
to attach to data or draw from data does that make
sense yeah absolutely like notes data imaging data
all kinds of data that's um not not so discrete
encoded data can be really valuable for any
research study so you know we were focused on
the coded data today but you could absolutely
design and people design nlp algorithms to run
on say notes data and then try to map those to
the existing codes so there might be things
that could have been coded but weren't coded
or you might just be going for a totally
different concept something that might not
ever appear in a code typically and create a
different kind of a variable out of those things
you know with harmonization and centralization you
get extra hurdles with working with that kind of
data but we are we are tackling
those again at the national scale
and and kind of solving those problems
it's just really wonderful to see um
what it you know how everybody came with
such open open-handed uh good intentions
um in the early pandemic and i think we all
thought we were diving in for a couple months
right right but um but it's so exciting and it's
such an honor for me to work alongside these
these experts you know whose publications i've
read and admired and and they're just right there
accessible to all of us you know you just join any
of these public meetings and you can jump in and
and work right alongside them so um
it's a wonderful community format and
one that melissa hendell one of the pis i
think calls social anarchy and you know it's it
it really is um a different model and one word
that we're trying to get attribution to apply to
people doing some of the work that gets hidden
and maybe people get credit that that wouldn't
always get credit for doing this work so folks who
are creating these large you know tools that can
be used across the community um giving them some
recognition as well as these publications come out
one of the things that you mentioned in one
of your comments one of your slides you talked
about the fair principles and certainly it's
something for us who are doing you know empirical
work in patient samples versus controls or we're
developing tools you know data and software are
things that we want to see be findable accessible
interoperable and reusable um in what ways are the
communities around this like taking that seriously
how are they opening these up making the data and
the results more reusable by people who are not
part of those communities does that make sense
yeah so um you know trying to align with
open source things as much as possible is
very important for for reproducibility um we are
encouraging everyone who's publishing out of n3c
for example to also publish the concept sets that
they used for their creation of their variables
because different decisions go go into that with
every group and you can try to describe those
decisions but having the actual you know list of
codes used to define something like heart failure
is also critical for trying to reproduce it at
your own institution and will save a ton of time
for those who are trying to reproduce the work
you know github is used for a lot of the odyssey
code and you know it's widely available
there inside the enclave there's kind of
a custom interface where we write chunks of
code and and create pipelines inside of there
not all of that is easily exportable to the
outside at least in a reusable way you can actu
you can pull it out but it's not really reusable
so we're working on i'm making that a little
bit better but of course anyone can join into
that in that enclave with a data use agreement
and then access any of the code that's been
templatized and um that's that's really i mean
sometimes there's so much available out there
that the challenge is not can we share it but
how do you find what's meaningful yeah what and so
we're also working on the documentation processes
around that so for the concept sets that we're
sharing um we're asking that people it's all
voluntary but people document the provenance of
that you know the aims of creating that particular
one um and the known limitations around that
concept says he would say we're trying to be
really conservative with this one because we don't
want any false positives for these reasons etc
right and that helps for someone who browses and
finds there's 20 different asthma concept sets
they can review the notes and say well i'm going
to start off with this one because that sounds
closest to what i'm aiming to do um and similarly
we're we're working to create a computable
protocol uh structure where um a lot of these
things like the pointing to underlying concept
sets the descriptions of the logic that creates
the derived variables becomes you know extracted
and exposed anywhere where it needs to be
exposed in any kind of lab notebook type of
a thing or any database as you're ingesting it
you can see that that data where it came from
and that can be tied to your protocol and you can
kind of point to these bits and pieces and chunks
so that will really help enhance reusability in my
team the logic liaisons we really work to to make
to make curated templates with curated
underlying variables that are broadly used so
as we watch the community work and we see a lot
of people doing something similar but different
we write code and we select concept sets
and we create good documentation around that
so that people can go to something pretty generic
that runs well though that they can take and
copy and paste and modify code for their own
purposes or just use the output of one of these
pipelines so yeah the reusability is is always a
a combination of the tools to create the metadata
and expose the metadata and share that share all
those artifacts and the curation aspect and the
metadata needs to reflect that curation somehow
one thing that is one of our our themes this
year is in addition to being able to do computing
against a resource like this or perhaps apply
artificial intelligence methods and and such is um
understanding the sources of bias that may affect
the ethical use of certain data um how you know
certain factors about our culture or society may
get baked into certain resources and anyway i'm
just kind of curious if in some of these resources
where might the challenges be and like for example
in some of these which are say associated with
the uh medical records um associated with major
medical centers might there be sort of a bias
towards you know large urban areas in contrast
to maybe more rural areas are those things to be
worried about as one is looking at these resources
yeah i mean i think it again depends on
the question that you're asking and some
you need to be more sensitive to
that type of context than others
we were just today actually working on
making it easier to access the social
determinants of health data like the sdi
index or a variety of other projects like
sharepoint and other ones make it a little easier
to have those facts tied to the patients and
you know it's possible now but when you have to
go and do a lot of custom coding to get there
you know it might dissuade people from making use
of that and so we're trying to make that easier
so people can stratify or use that when they're
doing matching it's very very important that that
the data be looked at site by site no matter what
you're doing again for completeness of variables
or you know use it you might use it at
the site in a mixed effects model to look
at the effects of that site yeah very very
important and do people when they use these
do they need to be um do they have to have like
city training or some any special training to be
able to have access to these uh resources yeah so
again i've been focused on n3c and you do have to
have human subjects training and you do complete
the and that could be your local human subjects
training it has to just be current and then
you have to do an nih security training which
is generic training for people who work there so
it's like when you travel with your government
laptop are you being safe with things like
that but uh you know we we do that um and
review certain policies and standards you know the
the data that comes out has to be aggregated at a
minimum cell size of 20. a lot of other database
data databases people might work with it maybe 10
as the threshold that's a cms minimum but that
just means you can never make a statement that um
exposes a group smaller than 10 you know even
when you look at all the different ways your
data converges and percentages of bigger numbers
and things like that you don't you don't want to
ever expose a very small group of people because
that leads to risk of re-identification sure one
final question uh one of our listeners is asking
um uh along with the um n3c data and all the codes
that it has and it's what did you say q was this
number right 50 million records is that correct um
there's over three million code positive patients
and about 10 million i think total or so i can't
remember oh my gosh well it's still a staggering
number 10 10 billion rows of data yeah but among
among those in addition to the codes is there also
um free text associated with those records as well
the notes data we are we are working on making
that available from all sites there are a few
sites that are doing some early work with that and
then but what would be available would not be the
raw notes data because that is just it's too risky
but rather the nlp pipelines would be run on your
local data to then extract some you know
synthesized facts about the notes data
well johanna thank you so very much for
summarizing all of these important resources
uh for us uh this is really uh an exciting
uh collection of resources we're particularly
interested to learn about your work with the um
the covid consortium and uh the promise that that
has for helping us to kind of get our hands around
this and all the codes that gosh this staggering
amount of codes that we're going to have to get
used to oh my goodness um but thank you so much
for for sharing this with us we really appreciate
it and um uh thank you everyone who is listening
with us uh we're going to be taking next week
off in honor of the thanksgiving holiday here
in the united states but uh with that everybody
have a wonderful weekend and we'll see you two
weeks from now um at our next biomedical data
science seminar series have a great weekend